how's go Marissa welcome to sing Spore
we already created our characters so I
guess we don't have to do it again did
you watch that video you don't watch all
my videos and you call yourself a bro oh
god it's Ken that wait
now it's Ken haha now I'm just kidding I
feel bad I don't feel bad
needs more fab oh god this is amazing
why is this only skin color blue and
green oh I'm so fabulous I like its make
a play I changed my mind I want to make
a girl god don't say that please alright
let's work on that booty
yes any game where you can drag out the
ass is the best game ever and out of ten
that's what I'm talking about girl let's
go in detail what did you say about me
it's where when you try and make someone
as ugly as possible and they're still
kind of cut suck yacht that ellipta get
that [ __ ] stamp where's the [ __ ] stamp
there it is my anaconda don't my
anaconda don't and I never listened to
that song so I don't know what's going
on there that's a very nice chin you got
there I would want to do dirty stuff to
that chin her name is Anna
anaconda she's a gold digger this is
keep randomizing nice body man this is
something about his body that I can't
keep it me my head around
Oh God that face don't look at me like
that I'm sorry there you go
he's a lazy snob who loves mobs there we
go we're done this is gonna be the best
playthrough of all time all the other
sims playthrough on YouTube just [ __ ]
ignore them this is gonna be the best
ever
yelling makes it true I've been swimming
since 2000 and 1995 let's press play I
do stuff
let's build house all right let's build
yeah and then inside here we'll have a
garden and a tiny swimming pool I should
be an architecture all right you know
what [ __ ] it I'm done building look at
that this is amazing look at that look
at it you're not looking thank you talk
what's going on what are they doing
[ __ ] ass man what the hell'd you just
randomly diss everyone looks so what's
with the red push-ups who does that
I don't oh yeah they're still [ __ ]
pools anymore why not if I wanted will
the pool I should be dam able to do so
Jesus what's happening what is going on
here
what is this what why can I do that what
is that this is a table ha ha ha ok
you're back it doesn't want to work now
that's great this little thing
what is that let me it's uh cured which
can make it huge it's amazing
why not that's awesome how big can we do
it is it supposed to be like that ok
what is up with that well let's keep him
here I'll call him Johnny its belly
guards our house
fantastic hopefully we'll scare the
neighbors away god this house looks good
oh the windows aren't that's a cold buck
shelf buck shelf
Rilla pits is that what they're called
these days buck shelves oh god Johnny
you scared me going an energising jog or
some work that fat to make that belly
jiggle girl she's done that was a great
jog wasn't it oh she's out again what a
check oh hello lady
oh hey oh hey yeah yeah oh she's doing
push-ups what is with this game and
push-ups
come on chain hit on that girl alright
let's give a heartfelt compliment oh
she's right there that's a rock tell her
a joke about penguins that's the
funniest joke I heard in my life we can
go for a hug now with her oh yeah first
phase baby how she left sign up a bit
stop her
Johnny do something Johnny oh you can
just walk to other neighborhoods that's
awesome
alright let's visit them amazing oh yeah
look at that strut that guy knows how to
do it Chan what are you doing that's not
yours Chen found eggplant frog really
Chen you're supposed to find [ __ ] is
that their security alarm we're in all
right let's cook it would be great if we
turned our house on fire I know that was
the thing in the first thing yep every
time you cook here like ah got it happen
again
oh no Chan what did you do go here Chan
you're gonna die oh they had a security
alarm system Chan you're not Asian
anymore we got some money for going home
that's I wish that was like that in real
life
Oh daddy yes I always forget oh god a
house looks awful well we have Jani I
thought I really thought a house look
good I don't know where I got that idea
Chan's ding dong it's ok became black
again Nets sounded weird Chinese like
dying oh we don't have a shower I forgot
about that [ __ ]
alright I gotta bail a shower you smell
chan take a shower what am i shower go
Chan you're not supposed to text don't
don't
I spent all this time and he didn't even
have a shower come on there we go
stop dancing already oh he can't go in
inside the problem or what is stopping
him from taking that shower and getting
that booty how is your problem Chen take
a damn shower take a damn shower
God what is she doing does she have
nothing but it's doing invite in that
works my mind just will explode and
Chen's penis how long does a man shower
I guess he really needed that shower oh
no it's just going yeah you ruin it Chen
well I hope you're happy
oh he's going after her Chen does not
leave without that purse Chinese going
for it she bought it she's a little
faster
go away an anaconda god damn it he got
turned down oh yeah we don't have a
kitchen do we [ __ ] I forgot about that
all right the kitchen will have to be on
the second floor wait where the [ __ ] is
Johnny wait Johnny what duck Johnny
oh mama corn that's beautiful hey it's
my best friend he'll belong in the
backyard you're Johnny - all right what
does he need to do go jogging that's
what he needs to do what is Johnny doing
I mean what is Chan doing I love his
walking posture is this amazing he gets
to sleep on the couch where the music
aah uh-oh what just happened I'm so
immersed in this game play
he's hungry well then [ __ ] kick some
food by this giant couch where's she
going now it's Chad it's cooking Ferrari
that's adorable
I didn't know you could cook Shawn does
not like this
who wants to sit there there we go oh
he's such a all Chyna's all alone now
you can see the sorrow in his eyes and
there he goes
alright bris gonna have to end the first
part here hope you enjoyed watching go
ahead and leave a like if you enjoyed
very much appreciate it and I'll see you
in the next one as always stay awesome
Rus I knew you where